[Music]
all right today's question comes from
matthew in illinois
my sister is going through a divorce
she's asking my wife and i to lend her
money for a new house down payment
when the divorce finalizes she could pay
us back through joint assets she has
with her soon-to-be
ex i don't like lending family money and
friends money because it changes the
relationships
i was wondering how would you gently
tell her no
this one's hard dave
i'm pretty strong when it comes to these
boundaries i'm interested you've had
this question for 30 years
um rabbi daniel lapin
wrote the book thou shall prosper and
he has a great line in there when it
comes to
uh you know people asking for your time
people asking for your money his
response in writing like a letter
for instance he's writing a letter
responses um i would if i could but i
can't
because my commitments
to this this and this are going to
prohibit me from being able to
attend this meeting whatever it is right
that kind of a thing
and so maybe that phrasing will help us
here a little bit
um and it might even be i won't
in this case this is my sister i'm gonna
look at her and say what if i could
but i won't i could but i won't
because i don't think you should right
buy a house right now
you're coming out of a divorce i think
you should rent for a little while
heal a little bit i think you're going
to make a wiser decision
a year even two years after the trauma
of the lost marriage is behind you a
little further
than you're going to make in the heat of
the moment and so i don't i don't want
to assist you in doing something that i
think is going to be bad
for you right and when you if you know
anything about
how the liquidation of joint assets
that's a mess it's never what you think
it's going to be on the back end of this
and i think you're right you can come
stay with us for a month come stay with
us for a few weeks no months long or not
or not but um i'll pay for your hotel
room but
yeah i'm not loaning you money uh and
you're gonna
at the end of the day i wish there was
an easier way to say this matthew but
you sit down and tell your sister you
love her
and either you can't or you won't i'm
not going to do this i love you
and i don't think you should do this
because i think it's
it's unwise i think you're going to make
a much better decision a year after this
is all over
you'll have your own money to do it then
and you won't be making a decision
during the worst week of your life
that's right and i want to walk all
through this with you i want to love you
as my sister yep
and not i'm your cheerleader here like
yeah put strain on yet another
relationship of somebody close to you in
the hardest moment in your life
yeah and she's not gonna hear it and
it's gonna be like i needed you when the
chips were down and you didn't come
through for me
and at some point you got to be okay
knowing you're doing the right thing for
the preservationist relationship long
term yeah henry cloud says that when you
set a boundary with someone that doesn't
have one
they seldom react well that's right yeah
and and here's the thing
she'll barge up against it try to knock
that boundary over see how firm it is
and check you can become a travel agent
for guilt trips and tell her you love
her
tell her you love her she just she's
gonna she doesn't need someone else to
judge her that's hard
when you say i'm not judging you i'm
just no i'm telling you yeah but she's
gonna feel it right you're saying hey
you're
this this decision's a bad one i know
better than you she's gonna hear that
that way and i get that and it's hard
um but man i'm not gonna hand you
gasoline in the middle of fire
and um here's some masks some matches
light yourself on fire yeah
you know and i gave you the matches so
now i i
if you'll slow down and make a better
decision i can help you more
yeah and it's it's not that you're dumb
or something like that it's just your no
one
when they're in the middle of extreme
trauma makes great decisions that's
right
and if you think that divorce is not an
extreme trauma then
you it's one of the worst right one of
the worst we went through a good divorce
i always want to go oh so now we know
why you got divorced it's the lying
but i mean off the air you and i were
just talking about man when you are in
it
you won't think clearly your brain has
some mechanisms to take care of you so
you're not thinking clearly it just
wants you to run or fight
and that's when matthew you as her
brother can step in with some hard love
and some hard truth
and keep her from making a tough wrong
decision here in the middle of a
hurricane